[inaudible]
well,
thank you everyone for coming.
It's a really special privilege and
honor for me actually to talk to Gary,
in my opinion, my humble opinion, the
greatest chess player of all time.
And um, you know, I've
really enjoyed his book,
which a I reviewed recently and um,
in know of,
is impressed with Gary's understanding
of artificial intelligence and a,
the latest advances in that. So, you know,
it's going to be great to talk
about that as well as chest today.
Thank your Marketo demarche you'll review
it over would be all of the protection
against all the tech guys that tried
to was this has to be for not being an
expert.
Well, I'm glad if that can be of use.
So, um, before we get talking about, uh,
you know, um, blue match and now she'll,
everyone's going to want to hear about
your insights on that and also machine
learning more generally.
And I wanted to begin by asking you
about growing up as a chess champion in
Soviet Union. Um, did you always
want to be a chess player,
a world champion of chess?
Did you consider anything else or were
you from a very young age decided that
this was your path?
Um,
I learned
how to play chess when
I was five, four, six.
I'm sorry I couldn't give you an exact
moment. Nobody was there to tweet about it
was late 68 [inaudible] 69.
Yeah.
Watching my parents trying to
solve chess problem. And, um,
I love the game of foresight and,
um,
ever since I'm still an old
was the game and uh, um, I,
I could feel that was a match made in
heaven and everybody around also could see
that a chess was a perfect feet for,
for my mind
skills. Yeah. Yeah. And actually you
talk about in the book about chess,
informing all of your thinking and
the rest of your life, right? Do you,
what do you mean by that?
What skills can you see yourself using
in the rest of your life that you love?
Yes.
Naturally, if you will engaged in, in, in
a competitive sport at such an early age,
uh, you, you, you, you
see many things just, uh,
uh, uh, as a reflection
of, of your chess games,
your engagement because
you have to play up to win.
It means you have to change certain,
um,
certain habits and certain
customers. Um, and, uh, um, uh,
what was important for me, that's what
I learned from my mother is, is it's,
my game was not just about winning.
It was also about making a difference.
And that's what helped me
to make a transition later
on in my life, uh, from a,
um, playing chess being number one chess
player for 20 years to other things that
I'm doing now.
Not pretending that I could be number one
and repeat my outstanding achievements
in the game of chess,
but still recognizing that I'm quite
useful because I'm trying to, uh,
um, um, uh, bring my chest experience, my,
what I learned from the game of Chess,
uh,
my analytical skills to make
the difference elsewhere.
Sarabia. Oh yeah. We should,
we should talk about a,
obviously the heart of your book, which
is that the deeply batch and you know,
I was fascinated to see
your, your take on, you know,
having gone through the Alpha go
matches ourselves on the other side.
Your take on it from,
from the player's perspective.
It's a,
it's a,
it's an interesting story because when
we played our first match and I always
want to remind people that the two
matches and I want the first one. Exactly.
We should, we should make
that very clear. So exactly.
The first match in
Philadelphia, uh, it just,
it was organized as quite
a low level event. Uh,
the corporation was not even
involved. Uh, it was, uh,
ECM behind it and the team always wanted
to challenge me and I had an experience
of playing was our plating is there, I
mean, 1989 when they had a deep thought,
uh,
the prototype from Carnegie Mellon that
they brought to IBM and it's turned into
a deep blue project. Um, and um,
everything has changed up the
game. One, which by the way,
if we are talking about
a watershed moment,
that was in February 90 96 in Philadelphia
when I lost game one of that match
because the rest is, you may
argue, matter of technique,
matter of time it was
like signing on the wall.
If the machine could be the world
champion in one game, then eventually,
eventually, yeah, I fought back, I won the
match. I want to get into and gain 500,
game six. But it was pretty clear that
the rest will be measure of time. Um,
and the first game, uh, had some kind
of record following on the Internet.
I think it's,
they did the numbers they had,
they will hide the numbers later on in
Atlanta that IBM run, uh, around, uh, um,
uh, the, the website there.
And suddenly the corporation,
a Google Sre,
these team discovered the huge
potential at other relatively low cost.
So, um, and uh, while the rest of the
match was still, you know, play to,
it's just what, who chest, then it
turned into a big corporate endeavor.
And, um, and I'm, look,
it's water under the bridge.
20 years ago I lost the match, but
I think, and I discovered the book,
I made many mistakes in preparation
and one of the biggest mistake,
and it's quite, you know, that's
why I was so upset with myself,
is that I didn't treat the IBM
deep blue as just an appalling,
the way you're treated Anatoly Karpov
where Vishy Anand or not too short for me,
it was a still, um, in
this, I was still part of,
of a great social and scientific
experiment of the end of the 20th century.
So I'm seeing that could help us to
understand more about how we humans make
decisions, how machines can play with
us. It's, it was not just, you know,
winning or losing big
mistake. Yeah. Uh, uh,
now for IBM would was just
about winning or losing care.
Yeah. And, uh, the, one of,
one of the big mistakes that I made as
just as I, while signing the contract,
um, you always have to
read the fine print. Yeah.
I hate them because it's,
it's when people ask me
what the IBM cheated. No,
they just bend the rules in their favor.
At states they followed the, the letter,
but of the spirit of the agreement and
for instance, one of the big issues, uh,
after,
uh,
after our first machine for they'll fit
for me it was how can I prepare if I
didn't have any games, this is the normal
way to prepare and look at the game.
So your opponent and the deep blue
in Philadelphia was a black box.
I had no idea what it was capable of.
There were soft,
I saw few games at machine played in,
in other against other computers,
but it was not,
it was not the machine that I faced
me now one year more than one year,
15 months between the first match
and the second match. And, um,
and that was under the impression
that it's, it's, it will be,
I will be treated fairly because
after my first victory, Philadelphia,
I went to Yorktown Heights, I said was
their team, they had this, this, you know,
similar arrangements for all
IBM labs around the world.
So the atmosphere was very friendly
and they change and, and
then it just, it's the,
when I eat nodes as I expected them
games to be provided. And then they said,
wait a second,
but can you read the games played in
official tournament's and of course the
blue hasn't played a single game outside
the lab. So which means that in, in,
in Maine 98, in May, 1997,
I face them face another black box that
I knew was much stronger than it's,
it's um, um, it, it was
before but still no idea what,
what to expect. I knew they had
a professional team, so they,
they made a massive preparation.
And I have to also admit my probation
was quite lousy because again,
I only just before the match and we did
before the match and realized, you know,
that's how difficult the challenge
could be. But also the, one of the,
one of the key elements
of the, of, of, of, um,
of this contract that I told
the overlooked was about,
um, machines rebooting. Hmm.
That's a big issue. Yeah. You
understand what it is. It's here.
I don't have to explain,
but general audience doesn't understand
that the moment you work with the
computer, you will never be
able to reconstruct the game.
So which means that is a whole idea that
it's the Ma Mat matches fair and square
and,
and you can always go back and to see
why the blue made this move or that move.
It's all over.
And also they're making,
maybe people don't realize that actually
I didn't meet, as I said, read the book.
They're in fact several
times there they're rebooting
crashed and then we don't
know. And then they came up
with a different move, right.
In a couple of seconds.
It's not, it doesn't matter what the move
was, is just the crash. You know, it's in,
if you played a match, anything but
the, but the problems was agreed. Crush.
You lost the game. Heart
attack. Sorry, go to synagogue.
Yeah, no, but it's the,
it had Ken Thompson. Oh,
that's the great condemned
or expert. Just, you know,
just who was there in
Philadelphia helping me.
He was also in front of the screen,
but on the screen you could see the
deep blues communication back to the
programmer, but you didn't see what have
they said anything. By the way, the,
the other way, again,
I don't know, but it's,
it's definitely created a lot
of tension in the match and, uh,
and we now have to losing game,
uh,
game to its essence and
how the story of its own.
So I was very upset and I demanded a logs.
And by the way,
if they wanted to play
a fair, um, a fair game,
all the head to do is a produced the blog,
the blogs.
And to prove that my suspicions were
not well founded, they didn't do it.
They just wanted me just to, to, uh,
to be inflamed because they realize that
while the blue was not that strong at
that time, I still think I was stronger
objective. And now 20 years later,
you can look at the games.
You know, you can take, uh,
a chess engine on your laptop and you'll
find out that many mistakes were made
from both sides. I mean one of
the, one of the most amazing,
it was not get given game too, but game
five, the end game reach an end game.
I was slightly better.
And everybody at that time in 1997,
I believe that was a
brilliant escape by the blue.
Now in 30 seconds to one minute depends
on the strengths of your, uh, of, of the,
the speed of your computer
chess engines like stock,
fish or comma will tell you
that the end game was a draw.
The blue made a bad mistake. And
I, and then I missed the win,
which nobody saw in 1997.
It's an including including the blue.
So that tells you that stay there, all
of the strings. And I think that's,
if we played it,
this should match the rubber match.
I still had a good chance of winning.
Again, it wouldn't change the sort,
the long term outcome,
but at very thing you could have held
them off for if I hit a full potential
maybe two, three years. As
far as the Blue Maxim to yeah,
I played two more matches with, uh, with,
uh, uh, deep roots and, and, and, and, um,
the junior in 2003 boats ended in a draw.
So that was a balance in the
next five years. But in 1997,
they realized that it putting pressure
on only one human player in a match,
they could,
they could achieve the result.
If you cannot make your play a stronger,
you can definitely, you know, um, uh, um,
in Mclean, the other player and, and,
and, and took him off the ballot.
So, so what I'm saying sort of moving
more to the present day now and you know,
how'd you, do you think, how have
chess computers change chest?
Do you think it's for the better?
It's just different. What, what,
what do you think about that,
that evolution,
this something that you said
that you know, it just, it's,
it's quite striking because you said,
is it for better or worse it's happening.
Yeah. Period is, as the technology is not
neither good nor bad. It's agnostic. It,
you know, you can do many great things
too. Is with, with your mobile phone,
but you can also create a terrorist
networks. So it's this, it's,
it's happening and we just have to adjust.
And, uh, as for the game of chess, uh,
it's different because young
generational chess players,
they learn very differently from us.
I remember I had books and not so many
books. You can use new books, you can,
you can buy in the Soviet Union. Every
book was cherished. And I had my, um,
my notebooks. So this is, and I,
when I, when I, when I went to,
to the top and played
world championship matches,
I had to also note books and just all
my recording my analysis and I treasure
them. I remember just, you
know, had couple of, couple of,
quite a thick notebooks. We was analysis
and they were, you know, just top secret.
And I believed in eight,
1985 in 1986, 1987.
That was real pressure. That was a
powerful weapon. It's like, you know,
the Magic Sword of Maryland. Now when
you look at this analysis was computer.
You understand what's broken knife.
Um,
but also when you look at, at
young young chess players and, um,
under the umbrella of
crossbar off just foundation,
I've been involved in working with
them and I'm talking about Kate's off
international masters, grand
master level. Um, it's,
it's such a different in the
way they approach the game,
the way they look at the pieces. It's,
it's, it happened time and again,
we are reaching certain position,
analyzing the game and they say,
bad move. I made a mistake
here. It's a fine why? Oh,
and then it's a long line. So the
machine showed, I said, I understand,
I could see the screen,
but why you think this move was wrong?
And they don't understand the question
because machine said so because it's on
the screen.
So it's,
it's somehow they are be
the minds being hijacked by,
by the power of the machine.
And one of the reasons Magnus Carlsen
was so successful and still a dominant
force in a wall of chess.
And I remember soon after working with
him in 2009, 2010 for more than a year,
um,
he never looked at the machine as an
ultimate source of wisdom for a much more,
was more like a calculator to,
to verify his own understanding
and evaluation of the position.
This is a big challenge, but
I believe it's not only in
chess, it's elsewhere, uh,
many people just staring at the
computers as ice or just being, you know,
being caught by, by the screen, expecting
just to find the solution. They're just,
you know, instead of thinking
for themselves. So that's
why I always bring Kiddo,
as, as, as an, as a piece of wisdom,
the classical phrase from public ucast
so the computers are useless because they
can only give you answers. Yeah. So,
but everything begins with a question
[inaudible] essentially until about
Magnus Carlsen you say that he,
interestingly, although he's grown
up in the computer chess area,
he's one of the most human, I think you
called it, or intuitive players around.
Right. So it's kind of
interesting. He's consistent.
Um, it's, um, it, yes, it's human
because at the end of the day,
20 years after my match was the blue,
more people playing chess than ever
before and the chest is still very popular
because at the end of the day it's,
it's a,
it's a fight between two
individuals and, uh, um,
what has changed is not a,
it's not just the game itself,
but the way people are watching it.
20 years ago or 30 years ago,
40 years ago,
the world championship match was kind
of in out in the streets in event of
absolute quality.
Even Karpov and Kasparov play the
game and one made a terrible blunder.
It could take time in the press center
for Grand Masters to find out to, to,
to whisper it mistake. And uh, it's,
it's, it's like, you know, this is,
it's something that you could use
warship today. You know, I, I,
when I'm watching what
I'm watching the games,
but Magnus Carlsen Corona and you have
thousands of amateurs from all over the
world watching it, you can, this
scribbling an staying was techniques,
machine shows immediately
that says evaluation drop.
So it's some kind of respect
has disappeared from,
from that sense it's a real
shame but also, but also it,
it added interest because people can
follow. They just, you a this days they,
they give access to their
computer and they don't have to,
they don't have to be strong players to
understand what is, what is happening.
And uh,
um,
what an interesting thing you said
actually about the chess computers.
And I wonder if it's going to happen with
Kara as well in the countries that are
not traditionally did at
chess or go because they have
access to these machines.
Maybe kids in those countries
can now get very strong, right?
Like magnus in no way or I don't
know whether that's, you know,
madness. It's a, it's a rise.
Meteoric rise was due to computers and
maybe it's because you are you in, in, in,
in, in, uh, in this environment.
You don't have to spend so much time
learning from other players. So, um, the,
the process of, of, of maturing for
the chess player is much shorter.
You have a grand masters at 14,
15 today. They know much water.
Bob Official knew 40 years ago. Uh,
just because they played many games,
they could travel around and they
could watch the games. So chess,
chess is a perfect match for four
Internet because you can follow the games,
you can learn,
you can analyze.
So the many things you can do that at
a dramatically increased the pace of,
of,
of learning and getting to the top.
So you, you invented I think the
concept of advanced chess, right?
Matt Mann and computer,
human and computer issue and cares,
human and computer versus computer.
Are you still stronger?
Have you tried that recently with
the later chess engines? Are you,
is that still true now?
Oh, um, yes. Um, yeah. Why licking
my wounds after the blue match.
So I sorta how about bring you
together just out of curiosity,
because as a way to segregate,
if I just can play with who is a
machine just against another player.
So maybe we can play perfect chest.
Now,
the interesting thing is when we played
these match was Veselin Topalov in other,
in other top player. Uh, in 99, he ate,
I can tell you the quality was not very
high because it was limited amount of
time and it was so new for us
how to use the machine. It's end.
Eventually I realized
and we had many events,
the so called freestyle events on the
Internet that proved that it sounds quite
ironic,
but you don't need a very strong player
to get the best result of human plus
machine combination. It could sound
like a Harris in now, but it's,
I would say that you don't, you
don't want a strong player. It's,
you need a good operator
and decent player.
But someone who will follow the machine,
I should guide the machine but not will
you use the machine to back up his or
her own ideas because instinctively
if I came up was a computer,
I'll try to sue. I'll try to make my
own moves. Yeah, you don't have to.
All you need is just to maximize the
effect of machines play because machines
are so strong now. All we need, all your
you have to do is just to, to guide them.
Sometimes you can feel no, just, you know,
slight correction, move here, move there.
So it's,
it's,
it's something that requires a
very different kind of qualities.
It's more about interface. So you don't
need a great knowledge of the game,
my weight, it may help,
but it's to the other side.
It may preclude you from a sort of using
machines power because you try to play
your own game,
which could be detrimental.
So it's, it's something
that's, um, you know,
I think you touched on in a few places
that it's become known as Casper off law.
Now write something like this
with the processes, right?
Oh, do you, and explain what that
is and again, and again, I just, I,
I relied on results of the,
of the freestyle tournaments and what's
happened is there that as predicted, uh,
uh, a human plus machine, uh,
beat super computer quite handily.
Uh,
but the most unexpected story was
that it starts as a described, um,
a relatively weak human or a group
of humans plus machine or machines.
If the class plus better a better process,
they of course they beat a supercomputer,
would know more. Remarkably,
they beat a strong human plus
machine plus in fury process.
So that's led me to come to the
conclusion that it's all about interface.
This is so many, um, ways of, of, of um,
empowering machines was our creativity.
So not our creativity was machines
brute force of calculation.
Actually you do it other way around
and then the result is, is it could,
it could be phenomenal.
Mm.
So it strikes me in the whole book,
you're very optimistic about
technology in general, Ricky.
Now in terms of like what it
might be able to do, what,
what is this a kind of process? Is
that a kind of blueprint for, you know,
in advanced chess of how you see things
going forward in other areas of life
with machines and humans working
together in a complementary way? Oh, uh,
I believe, uh, the future is a
self fulfilling prophecy and um,
I cannot stand all these, uh, you know,
doom and gloom predictions. Um, it's,
it was quite amazing when you just look
at ad the ad change of the trend in
science fiction from 50s and 60s,
where is all about optimism?
US [inaudible] was computers,
Robert's cyborgs flying to do other,
not just to other planners
but to other star systems.
And then it's,
it changed to a very dystopian
vision of the terminator.
Uh, and the, um, uh,
the metrics, by the way,
there's a speaking about the
terminator, you know, I just,
it's, I, I just recently,
I just got an idea, just having a lecture
in, in, in Dallas, Texas, earliest spawns.
I looked at the terminator,
I said, you know what guys?
I can tell you that that's another
proof of what you call [inaudible] law
because we're all watched the first one,
human versus machine.
But if you follow the number two or number
three, that was exactly what I said.
Human plus machine was a better
process of it being a super computer.
So it's the, yeah, and, and
I think it's this, it's this,
what we'll learn from chess is
that there are many ways of us,
of us sort of getting,
getting some, something new,
something positive out of those
corporation. And by the way,
these things are going to happen anyway.
So let's see.
What's the point of trying to slow down,
which is a natural cycle that we have a
technology replacing certain elements of
human activities.
Uh,
for centuries technology
was their machines have been
replacing blue collar jobs.
Now the difference is now machines are
threatening people with college degrees,
political influence and Twitter
accounts. That's, that's why we, we,
we hear all the stories about it,
but that's, that's absolutely normal.
I think that's, that's, that's
called progress. And, uh, um, it's,
if machines taking over certain nil,
certain menial parts of, of, uh, um,
elements or aspects of, of condition,
that's, that's not the end of the world.
It's, there's still many
things that humans can do.
All we need is just to look for new
challenges and for a new frontiers.
So we just come back from China
for the Alphago match against Kj.
And one thing that happens in go, which
is slightly different from is and go,
there's a tradition of players thinking
about how far off from optimal play are
they are in theoretical God play or
optimal play. So how far are you into,
do you think even in the top chess
computers are from optimal chess? I mean,
what do you think that the top e low
rating it would be possible to play chess
at is?
Do you have an idea?
No, I don't know why the idea because
I just, we briefly discussed, you know,
lunches that um, when you look
at the, uh, at the, um, uh,
date end give databases and
now we have all seven pieces.
That's a hundred terabytes
or whatever. Uh, and uh,
so every position is being
calculated from now to the very end.
And in many cases you just, you
know, we have a position that says,
made in 492 moves.
And I bet you that in the first 450
moves you will not see the difference.
So I could see probably fallen
20 moves. Yes. But it's just, um,
now I don't know what it tells about the
gay we play because the average human
games 50 moves. Now when you look at
average machine games, it's maybe 80,
90 moves. It doesn't mean that again
should be too long or what we know that,
you know, the game of chess is an
ultimate end game was suited to pieces.
So that's why I don't see any chance in
any future that machine will play e two
e four and we'll announce,
made in six, 2,755 booths.
It's not going to happen.
The number of legal moves in the game
of chess 10 power 45, that's enough to,
to feel safe. Um, but it's
not about solving the game.
It's about winning the game.
And, um, and I think there's still in, oh,
some improvement and machines could
get better and better as this, as the,
I mean is basically sky's the limit.
And today I still think magnus
was white in his good day.
We'll probably secure a
draw against the machine.
But winning against a computer today,
it's virtually impossible, is the, the,
the level of precision that required,
that is required, the level of vigilance,
it's just, it's impossible.
So it's a win win.
What would you use to Duke to play
with such attention? Um, so, uh,
machines we'll get, we'll,
we'll, we'll, we'll get better.
And by the way we see it,
we see an improvement all the time. I
remember this as well by writing my books,
my great predecessors, and then my
mattress against Karpov and then my own,
my best games and some of the
Games or seven games analyze two,
three years later, which is this new
version of the same engine and engine.
And just, I could see that, you know,
there's this, some of the, some of the,
some of the moves that are treated
as, as, as, as, as great. Uh, uh,
in say 2009 in 2012 was
Pablo Paulville computer.
I had my doubts. Yeah. Very cool. So
look, I've got so many more questions,
but I know I should, I should give some
time. A time. Is A, is moving forward.
So I don't know.
I should let the audience
ask any questions if you
put your hand up her high so
I can see,
wow.
Oh,
we'll silos. We covered everything.
Okay. Well let me ask another quick,
oh wait a second was the question again?
Yeah, yeah, Yup. Okay. Okay.
So now I went to that school.
I was too young when the,
the match happen.
So I don't have any personal memories.
Yes.
Um, but when they read stories of
it, it kind of struck me that, uh,
the match seemed like
everyone was great publicity,
but people really wanted to see whether,
well to put the bond,
whether you would is against the
machine. And I found this really, um,
my question is basically,
do you feel like this was the case or do
you feel it actually felt like a normal,
just match where people would
see who would win? Or rather,
did you feel like you've had
support from your side as well?
Oh yeah. I pledge of support. I can
tell you that, uh, most, uh, uh,
of people who wanted me to lose the grant,
the wall of chess now,
because I was Awol Chapman for 12 years,
and that was the first one I will last.
So that's naturally,
a lot of people wanted me to lose one
day and since I was unbeatable in the
human chess, so they, they had that,
they had a hopes in the machine,
but I had was fear that
was phenomenal. And, uh,
it's, uh, the, it's a, it
was a reflection of the,
of the famous cover of the Newsweek,
the brain's last stand. And, uh,
I remember when I want get one of the
match was a big celebration. I get,
it was on CNN. They, they
talked to you. Did you do the,
uh, uh, the two presenters,
they, they, they talked about
it and said, look, it's, it's,
it's a Russian playing in American
machine, but I'm rooting for Russian
and the questions.
All
right,
Dora, great from the Alphago team. Um,
humans seem to be more
efficient in playing chess
and go probably and that they
evaluate much fewer variations and
physicians than, than computers do.
I mean by many orders of
magnitude probably can,
can you give us an integration of, of, of
how this difference can come about what,
what are humans actually so
good at in chess that they can,
can do this so efficiently and that
they only need to examine so few, uh,
variations as compared to computers?
MMM,
no,
we can talk about sort of general rules,
but also you should remember that there
are different playing styles because the
way a carpet or myself, we'll look at the
same positions, you'd be very different.
It goes,
I will maybe look for an opportunity to
break through just to sharpen the game
cheek, create complications and Carpo
we'll bill looking for sort of long term
strategic advantage that could
manifest in the end game. It's um, uh,
those are the differences. Uh, what brings
us together is that as you just said,
Eh, we didn't have to
analyze millions of lines.
We couldn't,
so we could look for one or two options.
How do we know that those two
options are the best? I don't know.
I just said simply, I know this what it
is. Uh, but again, uh, it's the, it's,
it's the, then we, we had a
lot of subtle difference. Um,
I will probably try to go as deep
as I can calculating carp of,
we'll try to look for an option where
he doesn't have to calculate at all.
So we're relying on these
understanding because I,
many patterns you can recognize patterns
and then bringing in patterns together.
You can have a picture,
big picture. Um, that's,
that's what humans are a unique hat.
And, uh, that's, that's why for instance,
if you are, if you came up
with a computer, sometimes,
if it was all is that's, I
wouldn't go there. It's a,
and then it's quite interesting to like
to check whether machines calculation
proves it. Uh, but in many cases I
think it will be right. And, uh, and uh,
and the special at the time when
machine goes very deep, uh, and then,
which is it's horizon. And then you also
should look at the position and say,
mmm, it smells, it's, there's something
wrong. I don't know exactly what is wrong,
but something, something is wrong. Um,
there are also situations where you
have to calculate when you sacrifice
something, you sacrificed material and
it's, it's, it's a take it or break it.
So you cannot afford to be, uh, to, to,
to use your common sense because
you are material down. Um,
so my gay was Veselin Topalov
another one I played in 1999.
That's my longest combination.
So I,
I cannot tell you that I saw whole every
line there. It will, we'll be drew.
But Dee Dee, the combination,
the final position that I saw,
it's like an old lightened ink.
Just very quickly,
what will happen at the end
included, uh, the, uh, the, um,
uh, it's shitty. Apply links,
15 foot moves. So let's, uh,
um, ironically that because I saw
this, the final position as late,
the machine proved that I could win
earlier, uh, couple of miss the chance to,
not to escape, but to have test the end
game that he could probably defend. Um,
but, um, otherwise it's
just, it's, uh, it's, uh,
what you described is just another proof
of the MORAVEC paradox. That's the, uh,
I was going to bring up,
you should explain what that is.
Could you talk about that a lot?
But is that says machines are very good
at what humans are not so good and,
and other around. So it's
a chess. Chess is, it's,
it's interesting that chess was probably
because go and Shogi day we'll just
played elsewhere. But for,
for the western science,
chess was an ultimate test for,
for artificial intelligence. And a,
that was another result of 99, nine, nine,
seven match that the expectations of,
of the founding fathers of computer
science, like Alan Turing, Claude Shannon,
Norbert Wiener,
that machine beating strong chess player.
And of course the world champion would
be it, this is the moment for AI,
I have to say they were wrong.
So it's this,
this people was as intelligent
as your alarm clock. Have
the, a, a theory about the Moravec
paradox is that your explanation for that,
if you have built systems
like deep blue was then, um,
as the programmers,
you have to understand clearly enough
what you're trying to codify explicitly.
So you can codify it in a rules
or heuristics like deep blue ones.
And the problem is, is that for many
things that we take for granted as humans,
like, um, vision or riding a bike,
all these things we do implicitly,
we don't explicitly understand
well enough how we do those things.
So we can't codify it and that,
that,
but that's why I think that learning
systems, the kinds of things like Alphago,
my end up being more powerful because
they could learn how it from experience,
how to do those things like humans do.
No, it's seeds. It's one of the, one of
the rules that are learned, you know,
from my experience is that anything that
we do and we know how we do machines
will do better because we can
communicate it. So it's one word,
knowledge codified.
Uh,
so the big question is now
whether machines can ever do,
she really was things that we
do without knowing how. Yeah.
Yeah. No, exactly. That's the
big question, right. I mean,
I think you say in your
book, um, up til now,
anybody who attempted learning systems
and killing your great teacher bottleneck,
uh,
we're fell short against,
well yeah, the, against the spacey, the
hand code. So 40 years ago, cause it's,
it's in the beginning there was a big
debate and I think that states states, uh,
I've been touring car few people,
nobody wears a cure or the
fourth program in 1950,
there was a chess program and did the
trick was that there was no computer.
This is the only game that the, the
tutoring program. Yes, exactly. And just,
you know, just he put it on a piece of
paper and a calculated the moves and the,
and the,
when I spoke at decent Tennery,
so I asked now friends from Germany to
actually reconstruct it and put it in the
computer. We can actually play
it curing machine, pretty weak,
but it's nine 52. So, but they
believed, and that's interesting.
They believe that uh,
uh, the, the way to, uh,
to make machines playing chess, it's not
brute force, but understanding, but it's,
it failed.
This cost of failed very quickly because
boot force kept coming and studio,
it's all I got was like avalanche. They,
they, they couldn't stand a chance.
So that's why the,
the all the terms including one of my
great teacher may call Buttrick uh,
to come up with this,
with this parallel concept of
learning failed and buddy on the 60s,
early seventies, it was just,
it was, it, the store was over.
Now it seems that we're just like an in
seasons. We going back to two, these two,
these two, this notion, and
maybe it will prove to be
or fee Alphago we'll make above and
a copy. Then, you know, it hurts.
It's sort of a learning system, right?
So it turns out the go go needed to,
needed to happen.
What do you think the
difference is between go and
chest that required going to
have the, you know, have to
have this other approach. You
know, they couldn't do it.
The handcrafted approach.
Um,
you know,
it's a tough question because I have meal,
absolute knowledge of the game of chess
and almost zero knowledge of the game go.
Yeah. Uh, so, um, uh,
but for what I know is that it's the,
God doesn't have the same tactical uh,
um,
configuration. So you, you, you
have to, it's all about strategy.
It's a long term. And uh, and uh,
that's why it's far more difficult
for machines to learn how to do that.
But also if machines could
do at certain level, they,
they could be dead lift for humans
because it's, it's, they, they,
they suddenly become superior.
So my, and I, again, I,
I'm not sure just I'm sticking to great
expert. I still think that relatively,
if you compare the strengths,
I think the chess playing engines
are relatively stronger than Alphago.
Uh, it's in absolute ratings but,
but, but then you look at it,
but then the gap between its just because
the mistakes made by human players in
golf, they are deadly. They
are just the, they, they,
they could take an offer more openings for
the machine. So in chess, the, the, the,
the human game was always unstable. So
he's not as, as a state as the machine,
but I think in, in God, the, the,
the, uh, the depth of, of, of,
of the mistake could, could be, um, could
be far more significant than in chest.
I guess we'll have to put that to the
test by teaching Africa chest to play
chess. Right. And then we'll
have it, we'll say six.
That'll be interesting. And so how soon
Alphago can crush the strongest church.
It just engines, again, it's, it's
than he's thought about Alphago,
but it's about the nature of the game
goal go and chess. But I, you know,
would you be some pretty surprised
if our learning system could beat the
handcraft, the systems,
Erikson chest? Look, there's,
this will be another level of
experiment because the, the, the,
the current systems, they,
it's not primitive brute
force anymore. Now it says,
that's why I said it's this, it's
today. Um, uh, any, um, and by the way,
that's the woman that say people just,
you're looking at me in this belief
from nonprofessional audiences. I said,
free chess app on your mobile
phone are stronger than the
blue. No, no, no, no, no.
He says you are so losery I'm so loser.
It doesn't change it though. This is
the fact that it's that. Absolutely.
Absolutely. It's the now very good.
So I don't know if there's a loss
question from the ordinance. We
have time for one or two more. Yes.
From the lady the fall.
Yes.
At the front here
I see kids. Where do
you play? Oh, well cool.
Okay.
Yeah. This, the, there are
a couple of problems. One,
I'm a retired and I don't play
professional just to deep blues debt.
Yeah.
Yeah. Uh, um, I, I wanted
to blend 90, 98 and I, um,
I, I wish I had a chance, but,
um, that's, that's it. You know,
that's, that's, that's
um, old history. It's, um,
it's a spilled milk water under the
bridge share, you name it. Uh, um,
but I, you know, I, I played, uh,
played other computers and, uh,
as long as I was active chess player,
I never dumped a challenge. And, uh,
and that's why, you know, the, the,
this book begins with a story of me
playing sooty to chess computers in 1985.
It's similar than as exhibition.
Uh, I'm not sure what anyone owns.
Still owes,
owes the chest machine that's
from an antique chairs, machines.
Anybody here I still have on the CDC.
This is it.
So I played a play this,
it's silly to machines and
there were four manufacturers,
eight machines each and
I won all the games,
most amazing thing that
nobody was surprised.
And it can tell you the progress.
It's just from that match.
In 1985,
just there played in June,
just a few months before I won
the title beating Corp of, uh,
to my management's Dbu.
Just 12 years.
It tells you that certain
things happening and,
but I couldn't help but reminding
people about this match 85,
because I say that it was a golden age.
Yeah. Machines for week my hair or strong.
Yes. We're entering another very exciting,
I think, interesting era. I think a,
let's all thank Gary for
an amazing discussion.
[inaudible].